yet the united states has produced
dramatically better health outcomes than
any other country with a possible
exception of germany and i think we're
as good or better on a per capita basis
remember that on a per capita basis our
mortality rate is far lower than other
nations of Western Europe with the lone
exception of possibly Germany this
includes the UK Switzerland Belgium the
Netherlands Italy France Spain for
example has a mortality rate that is
nearly four times that of the United
States but you don't hear that you hear
we have more death but we're much bigger
country than any of those countries by
far so when the fake news gets out there
and they start talking about the United
States is number one but we're not
number one China is number one just so
you understand China is number one by a
lot it's not even close they're way
ahead of us in terms of death it's not
even close you know it I know it they
know it but you don't want to report it
why you'll have to explain that some day
I'll explain it since we released the
guidelines to open up America again and
this was two days ago a number of states
led by both Democrat and Republican
governors have announced concrete steps
to begin a safe gradual and phased
opening Texas and Vermont will allow
certain businesses to open on Monday
while still requiring appropriate social
distancing precautions and I can tell
you the governor of Texas Greg Abbott he
knows what he's doing he's a great
governor knows exactly what he's doing
Montana will begin lifting restrictions
on Friday Ohio North Dakota and Idaho
have advised non-essential businesses to
prepare for a phased opening starting
May 1st throughout this crisis my
administration has taken unprecedented
actions to rush economic relief to our
citizens as an example you don't hear
any more about ventilators what happened
to the ventilators and now they're
giving you the other it's called testing
testing but they don't want to use all
of the capacity that we've created we
have tremendous capacity dr. Burks will
be explaining that they know that the
governor's know that the Democrat
governors know that they're the ones
that are complaining through the
Paycheck protection program we've
already processed nearly 350 billion
dollars to 1.6 million small businesses
across the nation to keep American
workers on the payroll so we're asking
the Democrats to get it done this should
be bipartisan this should be a hundred
percent vote and it's really been
incredible the 350 billion dollars
that's been approved is so popular and
it's keeping businesses open and they'll
be open hopefully forever
our swift action is directly supporting
30 million American jobs
Amy Wright from North Carolina as an
example said the program is a game
changer for her and her family its
coffee shops and she has a hundred and
twenty employees many of whom have
developed mental and intellectual
disabilities and now they're all staying
in they're getting paid and she's got a
dream and it's going to take place very
quickly when she opens again so Amy good
luck North Carolina great place Scott
and Julie alder Inc helped lead a church
and owned a restaurant in South Dakota
with about 15 employees they were
already starting layoffs layoffs were
moving along rapidly but now they've
hired their employees back and they can
keep their restaurant open and
it'll be moving quickly very quickly as
opposed to not having anybody and
probably not having a place to have all
of these people employed she would have
been out of business you would have been
gone the Paycheck protection program
funding is now fully drained it's out
it's gone three hundred and fifty
billion dollars to small businesses and
in turn it goes to the employees of
those small businesses lawmakers must
stop blocking these funds and replenish
the program without delay the Democrats
have to come on board I used to read
that these were Democrat programs not
Republican seems to have switched around
a lot doesn't it have switched around a
lot the Republicans want it I think the
Democrats probably do too but they also
want other things that are unacceptable
this is about kovat this is about the
plague and what it's done to us isn't
about extraneous things that they've
been trying to get for years that our
country doesn't want them to have as we
enter the next stage of our battle we
are continuing our relentless effort to
destroy the virus my administration is
taking steps to protect high-risk
communities by providing funding for
13,000 community health center sites and
mobile medical stations in order to
equip them with the most advanced and
robust testing capabilities these sites
are incredible what they can do is
incredible the job they do is incredible
these centers provide care to 28 million
people living and medically underserved
urban and rural regions including many
African American and Hispanic
communities we're taking care of them
and it's so important because you've all
been reading about the disproportionate
numbers on African American and you're
reading a little bit less about Hispanic
but likewise Hispanic
communities the numbers are
disproportionate in fact we're doing big
Studies on it right now we don't like it
not right nationwide we've now conducted
over 4 million tests and Deborah will be
talking about that it's double the
number conducted by any other country on
Earth so that's more than 2 times
actually the number conducted by any
other country on earth you hear so much
about testing what we've done is
incredible and testing and I started
with an obsolete broken system from a
previous administration or
administration's but I would really say
administration for a different reason
because testing has become so advanced
over the last number of years and we
have the most advanced of all I spoke
with other nations this morning the
leaders and they all are talking about
our great testing capability and some of
them want to know what to do what how
can they get involved because they need
it for their own countries in Louisiana
Massachusetts Rhode Island New York and
other hotspots we have also tested more
people per capita by far than Italy
Spain Germany France and the United
Kingdom and all other major countries so
think of that in New York for instance
per capita testing is six percent higher
than in Singapore in fact there's a typo
it's 67 percent higher that big
difference I'd say there's a big
difference between 6 percent and 60 I
was looking at I said 6 percent doesn't
look too good it's 67 percent good job
out there
higher than Singapore 64 percent higher
than South Korea and 47 percent higher
than Australia so 67 percent higher than
Singapore which is a very advanced place
in terms of what they're doing my
administration has also been speaking
frequently with many of the governor's
to help them find and unlock the vast
unused testing capacity that exists in
their states dr. Burks
just yesterday the commercial and
academic laboratories in the States have
tremendous unused capability which they
can use the governor should use it
tremendous unused capability there
waiting for business from these
governor's that some of them complain I
must tell you for the most part we're
getting along great with them but some
of them like to complain but I still go
back because the hardest thing of all by
far by a factor of 20 is the ventilators
and now we are the king of ventilators
we have ventilators whether it be
helping other countries very soon we're
gonna be helping Mexico I spoke with the
President of Mexico he's great
great guy and I told him we're gonna be
helping him they desperately in Mexico
need ventilators and I told him we're
gonna be helping him very substantially
we're in a position to do that we're
building now thousands a week and
they're coming in rapidly and they're
very very high quality but we're also
helping governor's to develop strategies
to smartly deploy their testing capacity
to protect vulnerable and underserved
populations while getting Americans at
lower risk safely back to work so again
we have tremendous testing capacity now
a lot of people like the Abbott test
that we came up with Abbott it's a
brand-new technology brand-new test it's
great it's five minutes pump you put it
in and we're making thousands of
machines Abbott is making thousands and
thousands of machines but not everybody
is going to get that one but they get to
get others we have numerous platforms
which we'll talk about in a minute
unfortunately some partisan voices are
attempting to politicize the issue of
testing which they shouldn't be doing
because I inherited broken junk just as
they did with ventilators where we had
virtually none and the hospitals were
empty for the most part the hospitals
didn't have ventilators we had to take
care of the whole country and we did a
job the likes of which nobody we
assembled an army of young brilliant
people for the most part young a couple
of
older ones but for the most part they
were young brilliant geniuses that did a
job like nobody would believe I wish you
could have seen it round the clock and
now the rest of the world's coming to us
asking if we could help them with
ventilators because they're very
complicated very expensive they're very
hard to build and we have them coming in
by the thousands but you don't hear that
from even the governors nobody's
complaining about ventilators and if
there was a surge we could have
ventilators to them within hours because
we haven't stocked well almost 10,000
ventilators you don't hear about
hospital beds when I first started
everyone thought no hospital beds
hospital beds the governor of New York
correctly asked me for hospital beds and
we got the Army Corps of Engineers out
and they built them he needed them I
mean he we wonder I know he said that we
were projected we're not projecting New
York we're listening to the governor's
he wanted them he needed them we gave
him thousands of beds in Javits Center
we brought the ship then the ship we had
it converted to a kovat 19 and that was
a big deal by the way because of
ventilation and all the things we had to
do but we did and fortunately for him
and for us all of us they haven't used
either one very much because the numbers
have gone down significantly but it was
there and it was built that it was
beautiful 2900 beds there was incredible
what they did they did it in a matter of
a few days but unfortunately and it was
very good the relationship was very good
and I'm frankly glad they don't need him
but they were there Louisiana the same
thing I think the governor Democrat good
guy and he will I think tell you a story
that we had more than enough and I said
well we're supposed to build one more I
called him I said you know if we don't
have to build this hospital it was an
additional anywhere from five hundred to
a thousand beds if you don't need it
would it be possible that we don't build
it would like to build it someplace else
we're not build it at all and save money
which it's OK for government to use it
someplace else
and he called me back the next day and
he said sir we don't need it I said
that's great did you say that I
appreciate it and he didn't need it but
we were ready to go we took good care of
Louisiana which took good care of
Michigan we took good care of every
place we didn't we didn't miss a trick
and we're in great shape on testing we
have different platforms we actually
have nine different platforms and on
Monday we're going to be adding one
that'll be 9:00 to 10:00 I don't like to
count on them before they're up but
we'll have anywhere from nine to ten
platforms with a tremendous testing
capability and people can go and
especially with phase what now at the
same time just like with ventilators
we're building now the best ventilators
just like with ventilators our testing
is getting better and better I took the
first test the first test was not
pleasant this was not a pleasant thing I
said you got to be kidding to the doctor
you got to be kidding
up your nose and then we hang a right
and it goes down here and then we'll
wiggle it around here under your eye
and then we'll pull it out and we'll say
I said no that's it's there's no way
that can happen is that the way it goes
she sure this was a very unpleasant test
and then I was tested a few weeks later
with the new test that just came out the
abbot where they just touch your nose
basically and they put it in a machine
in a literally a few minutes later they
tell you if you're fine and I was lucky
in both cases because I've seen two
damage that this does to people but we
have great tests they've really gotten
better and better and better as we go
along but we have a tremendous lab
capability laboratory capability all
over the country and for some reason the
governor's then a lot of them are but
some of the governor's like to complain
and they're not using it we have
tremendous capability we're ready for
them and as we go along just like with
the ventilators we'll get better more
advanced and you know it'll be we'll be
able to do things that nobody would have
even believed possible but we started
off with a broken cyst
we inherited a broken terrible system
and I always say it our cupboards were
bare we had very little in our stockpile
now we'll load it up and we also loaded
up these hospitals and you know we're
talking about payment we gave billions
of dollars worth of things to hospitals
and we'll have to work that out at some
point in fact I guess they're going to
be working that out with Congress but we
we loaded up hospitals the federal
government loaded up hospitals with
things to take care of people that are
very desperately or we're not we weren't
worried about payment at that time we
said you'll take care of it at the right
time but we gave billions and billions
and billions of dollars worth of medical
Goods and medicines and equipment to
hospitals and we'll we'll work it out
with them but people don't like to talk
about that so we have done a job that
nobody believed this was a military and
private enterprises March we marched and
unfortunately with the other side
because they're viewing it as an
election how did President Trump - oh he
did terribly let's see he did yell he
did terribly Oh but we just got him the
ventilators that they didn't have that
they should have had we just got them
hospital beds by the thousands we just
got them testing that they don't even
know how to use in some cases they have
machines that they're only using 5% and
10% of the machine because they have an
advanced machine and they don't know how
to use it it can use it can do much more
so we've had people explain how to use
it so I don't know I don't think I'd do
that on the other side I don't I really
don't I think that here we have a crisis
that we have to work together and I hope
we're going to work together but we're
moving along and we're moving along well
we're moving along well this should not
be a partisan witch hunt you know like
the Russia witch hunt that turned
to be a total phony deal unfortunately
some of these voices though are
attempting to to bring this into
politics and whether it's testing or
ventilators or hospital beds or other
dimensions of our sweeping Public Health
response we have had a sweeping response
and speaking to the leaders of other
countries this morning they said this
incredible the way you've done this so
quickly you know we're only talking
about a few weeks since everybody knew
this was such a big problem and the rest
of the world is watching and they
respect what we've done because I don't
think anybody else I know nobody else
could have done what we've done and we
started with garbage as our experts said
yesterday America's testing capability
and capacity is fully sufficient to
begin opening up the country totally
indeed our system is by far the most
robust and advanced anywhere in the
world by far the rest of the world will
tell you that I spoke this morning to a
friend of mine president moon of South
Korea he just won the election he won it
by a lot he had a big victory which I
was happy about and he was saying what a
great job we've done in this country I
told him the same thing he said what a
great job we've done here in this
country so I appreciated that he had a
great by the way had a great victory and
we're very happy about that from the
standpoint of our country working very
well with him South Korea as we approach
and the approach that we use but as we
approach hopefully the downward side of
what's going on I think you're gonna see
some incredible hard facts and evidence
that what we did was right there's a lot
of talk about heard the word heard I
don't want to show you charts of people
that went a different way but it's scary
it's scary we would have had I think
millions of people died had we done a
different way and I think numbers are
just coming out where they're estimating
60
thousand people will die that's horrible
I would say one person is too much
especially in this case when it could
have been stopped in China could have
been stopped in China before it started
and it wasn't and the whole world is
suffering because of it but this herd
concept and everybody had to think of it
at the beginning because look look at us
we had the greatest economy in the
history of the world better than China
better than any country in the world
better than any country has ever had we
had this highest stock market in history
by far and I'm honored by the fact that
it has started to go up very
substantially that's because the market
is smart the market is actually
brilliant I've seen it and they're
viewing it like we've done a good job
they view it that way because if you
would have told me that we're at 24,000
or beyond and the highest we were ever
was we never hit 30 we were getting
close to 30 so let's say around 29,000
we're 24 we were heading down I did I
start to say oh well we may be heading
into territory where I started I didn't
like that now we're way up but if you
would have said to me with what we've
gone through not caused by our country
or our people or any I mean not caused
by certainly anybody within our country
but if you would have said that after
going through this horrible plague that
we'd have a stock market that's much
much higher than when I started much
higher than where I started and I think
it's you know I think we have tremendous
momentum we have a big election coming
up but I think we have tremendous
momentum first we get rid of the plague
and because of what we're doing with the
PPP what we're doing with the paycheck
as we call it I think we have a chance
to have these companies get back to
action quickly but our approach to
testing is based on facts
and very hard evidence not partisan
agendas or coordinated political talking
points Mike Pence who is a phenomenal
guys making the commencement address
right now at the Air Force Academy where
they're being very politically correct
everyone standing not six feet but 10
feet apart okay
and it's very different I made that
speech less yeah I'm going to West Point
I think they're changing the date to
June 13th because of what's going on in
New York they're moving it to June 13th
West Point so I'm doing that
commencement speech and they're going to
have sad because but it's a big start
they're going to have the cadets they
may not have the parents but they're
going to have the cadets the parents are
so proud of them I know at the Air Force
Academy where where Mike is speaking
right now they don't have the parents
they have the cadets they're very very
widespread and you talk about social
distancing I mean they are really spread
I looked at it they're using ten feet so
he's he's doing that but they're having
it is very important to have it and
that's a great thing that's a great
thing that's a big start so he's there
right now and I will tell you they he's
a gentleman Mike Pence a real gentleman
and they requested the Democrat senators
requested a phone call with him
yesterday and I think they had for the
most part all of them on like
approximately 47 I heard it was just
about all of them whatever it might be I
don't want to be wrong by one or two or
ten and have the press say he lied that
he told a lie terrible terrible whatever
it was but they have 47 and I guess most
of them were I heard they were so rude I
used attempted I said rude and nasty but
I heard they were so rude no matter what
he said which was all very positive in
terms of winning this battle against the
invisible enemy no matter what he said
they were fresh they were nasty
and it was I heard just a terrible thing
and I said Mike that's politics that's
what it is if we came into this room
today and said the battle is over
we have won it's 100 percent God the
Democrats would say the president has
done a horrible job he has done a
disgraceful job it is a shame how bad he
is you know it's it's this is the
talking points this is political and it
would be nice not to have that
especially when we've done the job we've
done I mean all you have to do is look
at the big the big V for victory or V
for ventilator take a look at it
everybody said they had us on that they
had a stake for what they had us but we
got him done at numbers that nobody
would have believed and we did use our
act
our production act and we use it but we
didn't use it we didn't need it like a
hammer all we had to do for the most
people we used it actually a number of
cases but the most part all we had to do
is talk about it oh we had to do is say
we're going to use it if you don't do
this and everybody was you know for the
most part good we used it a couple of
times because didn't work out the easy
way but it worked out the hard way but
whether it was masks or ventilators it
was incredible what we've been able to
do so this is a very critical time for
the American people and the American
people deserve real information
and responsible and thoughtful dialogue
from their elected leaders and from the
media the media has been some very
honest but some very dishonest you know
that you know I mean I even registered
where mark Meadows tough guy he was
crying he was clear there was a Maggie
Haberman you know she won a Pulitzer
Prize for her coverage of Russia but she
was wrong and Russia so was everyone
else they should all give back their
Pulitzer Prizes in fact it turned out
that the crime was committed by the
other side the crime was not committed
by this side it was committed by the
other side a bunch of bad people you saw
the reports coming out over the last two
weeks they got caught so Maggie Haberman
gets a Pulitzer precious a third-rate
reporter New York Times
and we put her name up here last week
you saw that people thought it was a
commercial it wasn't a commercial it's
like a commercial but it wasn't a
commercial was just clips and because we
exposed her as being a bad reporter what
happened is she came out and said mark
Meadows was crying and they made it
sound I said walk it and it's okay if he
did I wouldn't you know look but I think
he was crying probably really for the
wrong reason they had it down but he's
not a crier and if he was I'd know cause
I could tell you people did you know
that a very famous they cry and that's
okay too but it was a nasty story in so
many ways it was fake news and she only
did it because we exposed her for being
a terrible dishonest reporter she is
I've known her for a long way I haven't
spoken to her a long time
I made the mistake I take a picture with
her at the desk or a long time ago every
time she does the story if I say I
haven't spoken to her in long many many
many months maybe years I don't speak to
her she's faked a lot of people to fake
a lot of people we get a lot of fake
people but what happens if she writes
this story as retribution puts it in the
New York Times and the New York Times is
a very dishonest newspaper it's my
opinion it's not an opinion it's
actually from my standpoint you know the
the very hard thing to figure though
most people wouldn't know that but I
know because I know the facts and they
make up I said it today they make up
words sources say it most often you a
source to say you know what sources say
man
sources say means they have nobody and
they make it up okay and they have a few
other type statements that mean the same
thing but sources say is the most often
used expert in the Washington Post New
York Times especially CNN fake news CNN
they should really be mandated and I
mean mandated to use a name if there's a
source username say that Kayle Kayle
mekin and he said or somebody and you'd
find out that the
number one the source wouldn't say it
the sources don't exist I don't believe
the sources exist and I try and tell
this you know the beautiful thing about
doing these conferences is that we have
tremendous numbers of viewers and I'm
able to reach the viewers without having
to go through fake news where they make
a good story into a bad story so with
all of that it's been an incredible
period of time we've done a fantastic
job with a talk of other nations the
leaders of other nations are calling us
for help they're calling us for
equipment they're calling us for testing
capacities
now with the testing we are going
further Deborah's going to talk about
that now with the testing we have some
other tests coming up that are going to
be I think phenomenal I think they're
going to blow away everything as soon as
they come out and we're going to get
them out as soon as possible but I'd
like to ask dr. Burks to come up and say
a few words about where we've come how
far we've come and more importantly
where we're going from this point
because honestly it's it's quite amazing
thank you very much thank you mr.
president if we could have the first
slide I wanted to give you an update on
where we are as States and as counties
and as cities I know you all are
watching carefully the numbers have
shifted over the last few days what
happens when nations when states change
the reporting from confirmed to probable
so now all probable cases are included
they had to add them back in even though
the cases may Benham from March they
were added over 1415 and 16th of April
and states may continue to be adding
them eventually we're hoping that those
get accounted for on the day when the
perceptive cases or the probable cases
were counted but right now they're added
in and one fell swoop
so this is New York and New Jersey and I
think we all know how difficult and what
a difficult time both New York New York
and New Jersey have had
I call your attention to the axis it
goes up to 250,000 cases so you can get
a frame of how we're talking about some
of the other metro areas next slide this
is the 25 metro areas the top 25 metro
areas and you can only see the New York
metro area in this slide again the axis
goes up to about 300,000 includes the
New Jersey part of the metro area as
well as part of southern Connecticut
next slide but if I take New York out
and the reason I wanted to do that now
the axis is 1/10 of the previous axis so
that previous acts the previous slide
300,000 this slide 30,000 so that will
give you a frame of reference for some
of these other metros the reason I
wanted to show you this is this is
cumulative cases and we are still
tracking very closely the issues in
Chicago in Boston but on this slide I
hope you can see the yellow line that is
Detroit and Detroit and this mayor of
Detroit has really done an extraordinary
job and the people of Detroit have done
an extraordinary job with their social
distancing the other line I want to call
your attention to this is New Orleans
and I think frankly I was concerned
about New Orleans because they had a lot
of pre-existing comorbidities they only
they have two or three major hospitals
but a large cover a very large area of
geographic area and that other blue line
that you can see it's down right there
that's the Seattle line and you can see
that their response because of the
nursing home alert they were one of the
first states and the first metro areas
to really move to social distancing and
so they've really never had a peak like
many of the other metros next slide then
I just want to take you through some of
these new case graphics that was
cumulative cases this is daily cases and
obviously there's a lot of variability
and variability and reporting
but you get a sense over time when you
look at daily cases so New Orleans is on
the panel on your left and Baton Rouge
on your right but you can see clearly
New Orleans about a month ago very low
levels probably less than 50 cases large
peak and spiked around the beginning of
April and they have come down and they
have it down to very few cases again I
showed you before how the both their
syndromic cases have come down as well
as their actual casework
number of cases next slide this is
Seattle so you can see they had a much
lower peak and this is when we talk
about flattening the curve this is what
flattening the curve looks like it
becomes a longer slower decline but and
it ever gets very high and then goes
back down next site and then this is
Detroit and we always look at the metros
as a consolidated so this is both Wayne
and Oakland in Michigan and we really
want to thank the mayor for the
incredible job that they have done to
really ensure that everyone is receiving
the adequate health care and testing and
they've done quite a good job with
testing in Michigan but all of these
states Louisiana and and New York have
tested 30,000 per million inhabitants
those are some of our highest numbers
across the board and next slide and so
the president talked about on the case
fatality rates and we really we've lost
a lot of Americans to this disease and
we pray and hope for each one of them
that are in the hospitals and the
excellent care what did this graph
illustrates is the amazing work of the
American people to really adhere to
social distancing this was some this was
nothing we had ever attempted to do as a
nation and the world hadn't attempted to
do but they were able to decrease the
number of cases so that in general most
of the metro areas never had an issue of
complete crisis care of all of their
hospitals in a region and so you can see
our case fatality rate is about half to
1/3
of many of the other countries but China
on there so you could see how basically
unrealistic this could be when highly
developed healthcare delivery systems of
the United Kingdom in France and Belgian
in Italy in Spain with extraordinary
doctors and nurses and equipment have
case fatality rates in the 20s up to 45
and Belgium is extraordinarily competent
healthcare delivery system and then
China at 0.33 you realize that these
numbers even then this includes the
doubled number out of Wuhan and so I
want it really to put it in perspective
but I wanted you also to see how great
the care has been for every American
that has been hospitalized I'm an
extraordinary work of our doctors and
nurses and our laboratory ins on the
front line who have been doing an
excellent job next slide and then we
also wanted to show
does anybody you put us like that review
and this is why it's on television this
is why the reporting is so important and
I think you remember almost six weeks
ago maybe a month ago I was telling you
what Italy was showing to us and what
France was telling to us and the
warnings that they gave to us and said
be very careful there's an extraordinary
high mortality among people with
pre-existing conditions and we use their
information to bring that to the
american people that came that alert
that alert before we even had
significant cases came from our European
colleagues on the front line and that's
why we keep coming back to how important
in a pandemic and a new disease it's
really critical to have that level of
transparency because it changes how we
work as a nation it allowed us on over
march 15th to make allert out there
about vulnerable individuals and there
really the need to protect them and my
call out to millennials to really
protect their parents protect their
grandparents and get that information
out to everyone that there were
pre-existing conditions that put people
at greater risk that information came
from our European colleagues who were in
the midst of their battle themselves and
so there is never an excuse to not share
information when you are the first
country to have an outbreak you really
have a moral obligation to the world to
not only talk about it but provide that
information that's critical to the rest
of the world to really respond to this
credibly and I really want to thank our
European colleagues who worked so hard
to get us that information even in the
midst of their own tragedies and I think
that really shows how important
transparency is and we go to the next
slide we're going to show you this
really encouraging and great news so we
know that fatalities will continue to
lag because people are in hospitals
still and some are still in intensive
care units but these covert like illness
is this is our hospitalizations that are
related to flu per 100,000
Americans this is this year's flu season
and you can see our kovat like illnesses
and this is all of them probable and
confirmed cases our hospitalizations are
declining now that I showed you metros
that have made tremendous progress and
we've been up here many times talking
about it being six ten fifteen
additional cities and now we're really
just focused on Chicago and Boston and
Massachusetts and really some issues
that Providence is starting to improve
now as their relationship to the two
large outbreak cities but this is really
reassuring to us that the progress we're
making across the country against this
disease and I'm just really want to
conclude by thanking again the American
people for making these type of graphics
possible thank the data team who puts
these together for me so they are
working to about 3:30 every morning to
make sure that we have the most
up-to-date information that's the data
that goes to our supply chain
individuals to ensure that every
hospital in every state and every
community has what they need based on
data and to make sure that we're serving
the needs of the American people as
effectively as possible Thank You mr.
president the fact is that we've we've
been learning a lot from Debra and Tony
and so many of the professionals the
director PEPFAR we're spending the
United States with that help to the best
of my knowledge mostly in Africa six
billion dollars a year and that's on
AIDS what we've done for AIDS in Africa
is unbelievable we spend six billion
dollars a year that's been going on for
a long time nobody knows that you've
never heard that I've never heard that
six billion dollars a year
millions of people are living right now
and living very comfortably because of
the fact that we have found the answer
to that horrible horrible plague that
was a plague but we spent six billion
dollars a year and from what I hear it's
very well spent
done by professionals including this
great professional right here that was
the thing that you worked hardest on and
something that was very close to her
heart so it's you know it's something
that I think people should start hearing
the World Health Organization we're just
finding more and more problems and we
spend this money really well there are
other ways we can spend the five hundred
million dollars that's 500 million this
is six billion but we can find other
ways to spend it where people are going
to be helped we think at a much greater
in a much greater way we're doing some
research on certain people that take a
lot of credit for what they do and NIH
is giving away a lot of money a lot of
money we give away for years for many
years they've give away a lot of money
and some people complain and some people
don't some people are extremely happy so
we're looking into that also
they're giving away approximately as I
understand it recently more than 32
billion dollars a year 32 billion and so
we've been looking at that for a while
and we're gonna be having some
statements to be made about that thirty
two billion dollars a year it's a lot of
money and we want to make sure it's
being spent wisely and we've been doing
that by the way and we'll have some
statements on that and those are much
bigger numbers and what we're talking
about with national if you maybe a look
at with the with our friends from
wherever they come from you know 500 500
million is a lot of money but it's not a
lot compared to the kind of money that
would give out I think over the years
it's been averaging about thirty two
billion dollars thirty two billion
so we've had our eye on that one for a
while we also talked about the lab in
China where I guess 3.7 million was
given some time ago and we're looking at
that very closely chief of staff has
that pretty much under control but it's
money that too bad it gets spent there
but that was spent what year was that
mark it was four or five years ago six
years ago approximately so we're looking
at that and that's the lab that people
are talking about all right so we're
looking at a lot of things this
tremendous waste in our government we
found it in many different ways and in
many different forms and this is one of
them
this is one of them we can spend I was
talking to dr. Burks we can spend five
hundred million dollars using all of it
in a much more efficient manner if we're
if we choose to do that and it'll be to
the good of many more people than are
getting it right now but you look at the
mistakes that were made I mean so late
long after I said we have to close off
our country they were actually against
our closing off our country to China
when I did that in January they were
against that they didn't like the idea
of closing Norfolk they said it was a
bad thing to do actually and they've
since taken that back but it was a very
lucky thing that we did it very lucky we
would have had numbers that were very
significantly greater Tony pouchy said
that he said it would have been very
significantly greater had we not done
that so we made a lot of moves that were
good moves but it's still a very
depressing subject because it's a lot of
death and if it was stopped very early
on at the source before it started
flowing into these proportions you have
a hundred and eighty four countries that
would have been you know a lot better
shape but our country is getting back
and I expect that we're going to be
bigger better and stronger than ever
before I will take a few questions Jeff
the doctor mentioned China a few times
today clearly suggesting that the data
has not been good and when you tell me
do you think that dad is good when you
see that do you think that do you think
that's correct okay do you honestly
believe that's correct
dramatic contrast so my question
dramatic yeah it takes traumatic so my
question to you sir is why didn't the
white in the press why didn't you people
figure that out though why do we have to
put up a chart it's it the numbers
impasse it's an impossible number to hit
but why haven't you come up and said
there is fine now cooperating with the
United States to figure out what
happened and what do you want from them
now well they said they're doing an
investigation that they're doing an
investigation so let's see what happens
with their investigation we're doing
investigations oh yeah go ahead this
could have been stopped in the past I
know you don't want to Telegraph what
you would do but do you think that there
should be some consequences if in the
end you know China was responsible for
all of this well if they were knowingly
responsible certainly if they did if it
was a mistake a mistake is a mistake but
if they were knowingly responsible yeah
then there should be consequences you're
talking about you know potentially lives
like nobody's seen since 1917 and you
know the other thing had we not done
what we did in terms of closing because
there is that concept of let's let it
ride
but at some point I'm gonna have to I
don't want to embarrass countries that I
like and leaders that I like but you
have to see some of these numbers you
know in my opinion so we're talking
about maybe 60,000 or so there's a lot
of people but that's a hundred thousand
was the minimum we thought that we could
get to and we will be lower than that
number anywhere from a hundred to two
hundred and twenty thousand people but I
really believe it could have been
billions of people had we not done what
we did we made a lot of good decisions
but one of those things go ahead
that this was a unknowing pass situation
if you know anything I want to look at
the facts as they come in no I want to
look at the facts please thank you very
much mr. president
last week you claim that your charge of
everything yet the American people don't
understand why you're unwilling to use
the awesome powers of your presidency to
make American companies manufacture the
PPE and also the testing equipment that
you move you implement the implement
your recommendation enough but who you
had an encounter with tmn
recommendations for me and what has time
indeed is what my name is Doug Christian
with talk media news go ahead keep
reading your question the thing is how
to make companies build these testing
equipment so that you can do what you
want more doing we're doing it right now
with ventilators we have General Motors
we have General Electric we have 11
different companies great companies
building them for us all over the United
States we're starting to make our own
gowns as they call it we're making some
incredible things and as far as the
testing is concerned most of that now is
done in the United States we're doing it
into the United States our different
platforms and so I just don't think you
were listening complaining to which vice
president which senator day which
independent senator angus King he's not
okay
angus King is worse than any Democrat go
ahead he said that he was
livid actually yes he says that because
he's a he's a Democrat okay I guess King
is not an independent he uses that term
for whatever reason it's a waste of time
yes you haven't seen him okay you
haven't seen him no angus King is a
Democrat and that was totally staged I
heard that and it was totally staged
just like you read the question he read
his question yeah please in the back
please the one you retweeted from Paul
Sperry let's see if authorities enforce
the social distancing orders for monster
Ramadan like they did churches during
Easter I'm wondering I would like to see
that and you know I just spoke with
leaders and people that love mosques
they love mosques and I'm all in favor
of that but I would say that there could
be a difference and we'll have to see
what will happen because I've seen a
great disparity in this country I've
seen a great disparity I mean I've seen
a very strong anti-israel bent in
Congress with Democrats it it was
unthinkable seven or eight or ten years
ago and now they're into a whole
different thing between Omar and AOC I
say AOC plus three add them on you have
I mean the things that they say about
Israel are so bad and I can't believe it
now I mean so I would be interested to
see that because they go after Christian
churches but they don't tend to go after
mosques and I don't want him to go after
mosques but I do want to see what their
what their bent is yes please in the
back I just had a call with tomorrow
this I just had a call with ministers
rabbis we had a tremendous go with the
faith leaders no I don't think that at
all I am somebody that believes in faith
and it matters not what your faith is
but our politicians seem to treat
different faiths very differently and
they seem to think in I don't know what
happened with our country but
the Christian faith has treated much
differently than it was and I think it's
treated very unfairly yes please go
ahead the back saved an estimated 15
million jobs it's run out of money the
Democrats Pacific specifically Nancy
Pelosi have been blocking that funding
do you know why speaker Pelosi is
driving well she thinks it's politics I
know that gets good politics Nancy
Pelosi has been blocking it Schumer has
been blocking it and I think they think
it's good politics I don't think it's
good politics I think it's bad politics
but I don't care about the politics it's
so great for our country because we're
going to have all of these companies
that are good you know it's a bigger
employer well let's say it's the same
but essentially it's the same power all
of these small businesses added together
as the big companies about 50/50 and
it's so important and they will be
scattered if we weren't able to do what
we're doing and essentially we're giving
these small businesses that won't make
it they can't because they're closed
we're giving them money to take care of
their employees so when we open they can
get back into business it's been a very
popular plan even with Democrats I think
it basically passed unanimously twice
the first section which is 350 billion
so we're trying to get 250 Nancy Pelosi
is blocking it she sits in her house in
San Francisco overlooking the ocean and
she doesn't want to come back she
doesn't want to come back she doesn't
want to come back to DC she's got to get
back and get this thing approved it's
very important please
what goes through your mind when you see
these plates a girl probably be chasing
Lord or is that a concern for when we
stop seeing some of these restrictions
being lifted well as I described we go
Metro by Metro county-by-county and so
I'd have to link that with a specific
County and look at their case rates I
believe the governor and the public
health system that Florida has they have
some of the best County Public Health
individuals I have ever had to deal with
they are amazing that as I had to work
with them under hiv/aids so if the
health at the county health directors
believe that that's appropriate for
their County then I I'm not gonna second
judge an individual's approach to this
because every I can't see into every
single County and load the low rate so I
get to see there's no cases so I don't
know if that's a County with very small
cases or not but I think their county
health efficient and many of the
counties as you know are really free of
this horrible enemy so we're opening up
you'll be seeing a lot of this country
start to open up fairly quickly yes
please you've mentioned the importance
of social distancing push for example of
Steven Moore so when you appointed to
your open the country task force is
organizing a protest in Wisconsin but
are they in a sense protesting your very
own guidelines well we have a
flexibility I didn't see what Steven
said I can tell you is a very good
economist he's been calling shots right
sorry he said we need to be the Rosa
Parks of government in justices
well there is a lot of injustice when
you look at Virginia where they want to
take your guns away if they want to
violate your Second Amendment when you
look at I mean look I'm getting along
very nicely with the governor of
Michigan but she has things don't buy
paint don't buy roses don't [ __ ] I mean
she's got all these crazy things I
really believe somebody sitting in their
boat in a lake should be okay
they shouldn't arrest people some of
them are being unreasonable I really
believe that they're being unreasonable
but I think Virginia is a great case
though because they're using this
they're trying to take your guns away in
Virginia and if people in Virginia
aren't aren't careful that's what's
going to happen to them so yeah I mean I
could see where he's coming from I think
it's a strong statement strong statement
because hopefully this will be over very
soon for all of us but some have gotten
carried away they have absolutely gotten
carried away purchasing your social
distancing guidelines I mean I know this
there are a lot of protests out there
and I just think that some of the
governor's have gotten carried away you
know you have a lot of people that don't
have to be told to do what they're doing
they've been really doing everything
we've asked and we have a few states
where frankly I spoke to the governor's
and I could have gotten him to do if I
wanted to do what would have been
perhaps politically correct but they've
been doing incredibly anyway and as one
of them said everybody's doing exactly
the same in fact our record is better
than states where they're under a
mandate or you know where they've agreed
to do certain things now we have some
great states out there we have
incredible people in our country and for
the most part that it's a strong
statement but I understand where it's
coming from and I think one of the
Great's would be one of the really
important places that people really have
to start looking at is what's going on
in Virginia because that's a mess with
the government with really a governor
that's under siege anyway yeah please
you know with a beautiful head of white
hair go ahead
I'll tell you if I like is here in about
a minute after he asked the question
point though does the tweeting about in
the face of Virginia and linking the
Second Amendment to some of these issues
about lifting some of these restrictions
in these states not actually pose a
concern for the governor and civil
unrest and essentially no faces I have a
second question well I think just for
that question
I think that's an easy one that's not
even politics were entitled to a second
amendment and he's trying to take the
second meaning that state is trying to
take the Democrats in that state the
Republicans are fighting it they're
trying to take that that second
amendment right that second amendment
right away
to me that's Liberty that's when I say
liberate Virginia I would say liberate
Virginia when that kind of thing happens
and where does it all stop so I think
it's a very good analogy go ahead sir I
mean is this the right time to kind of
bring in a second amendment issue I
think when they talked about taking your
guns away and if you notice at the
beginning of this pandemic though a more
gun sold I think then at almost any time
in history because so it's obviously a
big issue and then you have them working
and signing documents trying to take
your your second Amendment away
essentially so I do think it's an
appropriate time to bring it up go ahead
go ahead second thing as we got a kind
of extraordinary slew of events from
adversaries North Korea Russia you know
China and Iran all pushing back on US
policy or toying with US military forces
what's your message was in these
countries who may be trying to take it
back no we had a very good relationship
with Russia we worked on the oil deal
together I was with one by telephone
king of Saudi Arabia and the President
of Russia Vladimir Putin we worked out a
deal on oil there was a very important
deal to them and to us and to Saudi
Arabia it was in a deadlock you know it
you covered it very well actually Wall
Street Journal covered that very well I
worked with Putin and with the King on
that and President Putin was a total
gentleman and it was very important to
get that done and the king was
great and we actually had to bring in
Mexico because Mexico was a lone holdout
or they showed great flexibility you
know the sewer no I think we're doing
fine yeah sure it's North Korea see
they're testing short-range missiles and
you know been doing it a long time I
received a nice note from him recently
it was a nice note I think we're doing
fine look if I wasn't elected you would
right now be at war with North Korea
okay I'll tell you for your people that
don't understand the world and they
don't understand how life works if I
wasn't elected you would right now maybe
the world would be over hopefully with a
victory but if you remember when I first
came in we didn't have ammunition not a
good way to fight a war
President Obama left us no ammunition
okay and he left us virtually no medical
and ventilators he left us the cupboard
was dry right the cupboard was dry
no I think right now you'd be at war
essentially in some form be over it
would be raging with North Korea if I
weren't president and we're doing just
fine with North Korea just fine let's
see how it all ends up you know in the
meantime they said Oh Trump's give it up
and then he said oh really what's he
giving up and they said I don't know
then they said he met oh I meant I meant
no I have a good relationship with kim
jonghwan that's not a bad thing to have
a good relationship Obama wanted a
relationship he wouldn't meet with Obama
wouldn't meet with him okay have a good
relationship with him we met at the line
I stepped over the line the first time
anything like that so right so good it's
just it's good but when they say the
stupid people I call them stupid people
or the haters they say trips given up so
much really
I've actually increased the sanctions
China's been very good on the board or
in fact right now the border is stone
called close between China and North
Korea our relationship with China was
good until they did this once we found
out about this once we found out look we
just made a trade deal with China's
gonna have to buy 250 billion dollars a
year on our product 50 billion from the
farmers 40 to 50 billion from the
farmers the relationship was good when
we were signing that but
then all of a sudden you hear about this
so it's a big it's a big difference you
know the question was asked would you be
angry at China well the answer might
very well be a very resounding yes but
it depends was it a mistake that got out
of control or was it done deliberately
okay it's a big difference between those
two in either event they should have let
us go in you know we asked to go in very
early and they didn't want us in I think
they were embarrassed I think they knew
it was something bad I think they were
embarrassed but you know no I think
we're doing very well
so you said Russia you said China you
said North Korea Iraq when I came in or
on was a terror
we had 82 points of fighting we had 18
points of major confliction the first
week I said tell me about Iran sir we
have 18 points of confliction meaning
Yemen Syria or Iraq they were going into
Iraq all over the place they're much
different nation right now I stopped
that horrible deal horrible deal and
they want to talk except that Kerry
violated the Logan act he made the deal
and he doesn't want them and I could
deal because I would have made a deal in
my opinion except that John Kerry when
he who made the deal original which is a
stupid deal to make it 150 billion
dollars gave him 1.8 billion in cash in
green that would be more than this room
ten times with hundred-dollar bills that
you could fill up this room ten times
with hundred-dollar bills and it's not
that small room and I say he violated
the Logan Act I think it was a major
violation I think we would have had a
deal of it wasn't for John Kerry but he
doesn't want to be number one
embarrassed no but to he said let's wait
to left of the election made me sleepy
Joe Biden's gonna win and if sleepy Joe
Biden wins you'll own the United States
and China will own the United States
China's paid us you know from The Wall
Street Journal hundreds of billions of
dollars is a trade tariffs and we gave a
lot of that money a small percentage but
a lot of money to the farmers and it
kept the farmers going great all right
but hundreds will get we're getting ten
billions of dollars in tariffs and by
the way for those of you that say oh
we're paying China devalued their
currency in order to pay these we didn't
pay China pay they don't like to write
that they also added money into their
system so they paid for that no I think
you have numerous countries waiting to
see whether or not sleepy Joe wins
because if sleepy Joe won they own our
country they will take our country you
know we had go back two months we had by
far and the China was supposed to catch
us you know better than anybody Wall
Street Journal for years I've heard by
2019 China will catch us there's only
one problem Trump got elected in 2016
that was a big difference and we were
going leaps and bounds above China and
before the problem with the plague right
China was having the worst year they've
had in 67 years that was before the
plague now they're getting really hurt
and so is everybody getting hurt I don't
want him to get hurt but they're all
getting hurt everybody's getting hurt
it's a horrible thing that's happened
but we had the greatest economy in the
world by far
China isn't even close go back two
months and we're gonna keep it that way
but when you mentioned Iran Iran is a
much different country than it was when
I first came in Iran was going to take
over the entire Middle East right now
they just want to survive they're having
protests every week they loaded up with
the plague which I don't want I've
offered to help them if they want if
they need ventilators which they do I
would send them ventilates we have
thousands of excess ventilators coming
in and and here we have a stockpile of
ventilators and we're starting to send
them so that hospitals can fill up their
stockpile which they should have New
York had a chance to get 16,000
ventilators and they chose not to do it
and I understand that it's a hard
decision for a thing that may or may not
happen I fully understand that I'm not
even complaining about that I'm only
saying this Iran was a terror when I
came into office right now they don't
want to mess around with us they don't
want to mess around with us two things
North Korea same sanctions we've always
had except more
we haven't given anything I think you'll
hopefully take that back to the Wall
Street Journal because they really don't
understand it they really don't and with
with Iran I mean that's a different
country right now and they want to make
a deal the only reason they don't
they're being shamed in because the guy
that gave them the sweetheart didn't
want to met with him many times he
should have never met with him and in my
opinion he's shown him don't wait maybe
Trump will lose and then you can
negotiate with a patsy
with a weak guy and you'll take over the
between you and Russia
nobody's been tougher on Putin he knows
it better than anybody nobody been
tougher on Putin than me look at the
sanctions look at what I did with their
pipeline going into Europe nobody even
knew about it I exposed it now everybody
talks about it I think it's a terrible
thing for Germany to do but at the same
time I have a very good relationship
with Putin and I was able to get I was
able to make a deal with Russia and
Saudi Arabia and OPEC plus they call it
OPEC plus that's going to save us Texas
North Dakota Oklahoma other states
energy states going to save us hundreds
of thousands of jobs and in fact your
paper wrote an incredible editorial for
a change the Trump made a great deal for
our country that was a nice thing I was
shocked to see it coming out of the Wall
Street Journal thank you all very much
we'll see you tomorrow thank you